all right if we want to think about
foreign policy and Trump if I say to you
what was Donald Trump's most
controversial foreign policy position
during his campaign and by controversial
I mean controversial to his own base
right given that he's a Republican
trying to convince other Republicans to
vote for him what was Trump's most
controversial position on foreign policy
your first reaction would probably be
wait a second Trump had foreign policy
positions after you get past that you
would say all right my second reaction
is it's the war on Iraq right on foreign
policy Trump ardently stridently said
unequivocally said that he considered
the 2003 invasion of Iraq the Iraq war
that was carried out by president george
w bush to have been a total and complete
blunder he slammed george w bush
countless times over it he said he never
would have gone in now the truth back
then was that before and during the Iraq
war Trump did say many times that he
supported it or that he would have gone
and he said it on the Howard Stern Show
during an interview he said at other
times but that's not what I want to
focus on right now what I want to focus
on is that Donald Trump ran on the Iraq
war was a total disaster Donald Trump
has now replaced his second national
security adviser HR McMaster with Iraq
war architect cheerleader and maniac
John Bolton okay the big announcement
came on obviously Twitter where Donald
Trump said I am pleased to announce that
effective April 9 2018 Ambassador John
Bolton will be my new national security
adviser I'm very thankful for the
service of general HR McMaster who has
done an outstanding job and will always
remain my friend there will be an
official contact handover on April 9th
the he will always remain my friend
thing it sounds kind of like elementary
school IIIi don't want to focus too much
on that but that that's weird we're
talking about issues of national
security and ultimately is the important
thing whether the guy will still be your
friend after you fire him I don't think
so but that's not what I want to focus
on what I want to focus on is
if as Trump claims he believes that the
Iraq war was an unmitigated disaster why
do you bring in one of the biggest
advocates of starting that war and the
answer more than likely is to start a
different war one that I guess you think
will go better than the Iraq war went
again if you believe Donald Trump on
this and who better to start Wars than
John Bolton I've said before that if I
was picking advisors or cabinet members
I never would have hired Rex Tillerson I
never would have hired HR McMaster I
never would hire Jim mattis but in the
context of Trump's inner circle
Tillerson McMaster and mattis are some
of the more moderate voices that might
direct Trump away from sort of erratic
and unhinged military action two of
those three voices of somewhat reason
are now gone and Bolton is coming in so
the question is what Wars might Trump
want to start what Wars might John
Bolton be interested in starting and the
top prospects in no particular order are
Iran and North Korea interestingly
Bolton is also pretty unhinged on Russia
so even in the context of all the
Russia's stuff that we've been following
it's not even off the table that if
Trump really starts to listen to Bolton
then there's every expectation that
Bolton will have Trump's ear that Bolton
might start trying to push Trump on
Russia we're already seeing that today
with the decision made to expel 60
Russians from the United States based on
Russian involvement in that UK poisoning
or presumed believed Russian involvement
in that poisoning that's sort of another
story we'll talk about that on a
different day but the real immediate
threat is what does Trump want to do in
Iran what does Trump want to do in North
Korea and who is left that would try to
talk Trump out of it it's not going to
be Stephen Miller Jim mattis I guess
might try and he could fail if opposed
by John Bolton who Trump really seems to
like the idea of having around him and
then the other angle here is generally
having someone much more aggressive and
less conciliatory on Trump's side in
advance of the the start of these talks
that are believed at some point to
that will take place with North and
South Korea right in a couple of months
supposedly those those are going to
start so this is if you're looking to
start wars this is the guy that you
bring in right you bring in John Bolton
and the other story here is that since
the selection of Bolton itself is is
pretty insane and disturbing there's
less discussion of this but were 14
months in and Trump's already on his
third National Security Advisor right
one who first national security adviser
was indicted and we're not going to get
into that in detail now we've talked
about the chaos in the White House
that's part of this as well it's just
more of that but Bolton specifically
coming in is a real signal to a
particular war Hawk wing of the
Republican Party and I thought that this
was specifically what Trump wasn't going
to do right all along we were told hey
you know what if Hillary gets in she'll
go to war with Syria or she'll go to war
here or there it's Killary Killary in
chief etc etc and in the end the moves
that Trump is making are to push out the
more moderate voices that say hey hold
it let's let's scale back a little bit
on North Korea let's scale back a little
bit on Iran and you bring in war maniac
and Chief John Bolton during the
campaign it wasn't just that Donald
Trump called the Iraq war a blunder yeah
he also claims that the Bush
administration lied to get us into that
war chief among the liars would have to
be John Bolton Yeah right I mean
certainly you know you had condi rice
you had : Powell but Rumsfeld Wolfowitz
one of the architects but this was one
of the main guys so bringing him is
weird and then as far as the firings and
the revolving door goes it appears as
though the VA secretary is also going to
be fired soon but plenty of time to talk
about that when it happens today's
program is sponsored in part by the
breach podcast a podcast team started
looking into the biggest hack in history
and ended up right in the middle of the
story mysterious voicemail disappearing
files it started to get personal and
breach is a new podcast that takes you
inside the world's biggest hacks they
set out to answer the questions about
the hack of a huge American company and
they found themselves investigating a
Russian conspiracy subscribed to breach
BR EA CH in your podcast app right now